change lives change the world I've
always been interested in how to use
scientific theory to help people so you
know my interests as as a researcher are
is in bridging scientific theories
between social psychology with with
application using theory to help solve
social problems message of the research
that we've been doing has been to show
how relatively brief social
psychological interventions can have
significant effects on important social
outcomes such as education we've been
testing the effects of various kinds of
what we call social psychological
interventions on outcomes such as
academic performance GPA health outcomes
like BMI when we've been struck by is
how how theoretically informed and
precisely targeted interventions even
when small can have lasting and large
effects so what we did was to randomly
assign some students to complete this
writing exercise in which they focused
on an important value other kids
completed a more neutral control
condition in which they wrote about
their daily routine or an unimportant
value and then we followed the kids for
actually two years what we found was
that those children those
african-americans who had received the
affirmation did better academically and
this effect persisted for two years
specifically they got better grades they
were lifted up sufficiently so that
there was a closure in the racial
achievement gap of roughly thirty
percent over two years probably one way
to give an intuitive feel for the nature
of this effect is that we found for
instance that the number of kids getting
a D or below in the first quarter of
this class after the intervention was
given fell from about 20% to 10% it was
this was an intervention that was based
on a lot of previous research a lot of
psychological theory it seems relatively
small but one of the things we've been
thinking is that perhaps these things
that seem small actually aren't so small
that given being given the opportunity
to affirm an important source of value
in a threatening context might actually
be a big experience like a sort of water
on part soil effect for some of this
these students school as for all of us
school or work and be chronically
threatening and the problem comes when
the threat gets it gets too intense and
what worked by Claude Steele's dispenser
Josh Aronson and our group as well as
has shown is that regardless of the
actual prejudice in a school environment
the perception that I could be
negatively stereotyped or discriminated
against can cause stress and very small
subtle cues can sort of bring about this
stress for instance if a professor makes
a reference to popular culture that an
international student doesn't quite
understand that could kind of convey a
message of alienation or make the person
feel more alienated than they otherwise
might he's very kind of small cues but
also not so small cues can set in motion
this this stress reaction and that can
have a regardless of the actual level of
prejudice in the environment and that's
really important so they enabled the
expression of what's already there and
the student or the school environment if
a kid feels stressed out they won't be
able to approach their teacher for help
with ease
they won't be able to explore
opportunities for growth and learning as
much as they could otherwise the
interventions by blowing up a sense of
positive regard and self integrity
enable my children to seize on the
opportunities for learning that are
there already and if they're not there
they're not gonna have much of an effect
the premise of this research was was
that stress is really bad for health
outcomes at least when prolonged and
chronic or repetitive we're really
interested in and this is with my
colleagues Greg Walton and Carol Dweck
is how to scale up these interventions
to reach more more kids
I think the Devils in the details and a
lot of these interventions we spend a
lot of time getting the details right
working with the kids to find values
that are relevant working in the
specific context to make the writing
exercise intelligible and impactful
there's a lot of stuff under the hood in
the preparation of these things we're
not just throwing the intervention at
people small differences between
individuals can compound over time and a
lot of work in school settings if I do
poorly poor performance begets worse
performance begets worse performance and
this repeating cycle and so if you can
interrupt that repeating chain early
sufficiently early when it's embryonic
then you might have a lasting effect on
a kid's trajectory through school
through their career through their life
change the world